[Musique]
des précautions utiles avant de cuisiner
coiffé ses cheveux mettre un tablier se
laver les mains
pour réaliser la mousse au chocolat 250
g de chocolat à cuire 6 e 2 cuillères à
soupe de lait 100 g de sucre
[Musique]
60 g de beurre
le matériel affoué mécanique saladier et
cuillère en bois
[Musique]
où
ce feu très doux qui fait fondre le
chocolat cassé en morceaux puis y ajoute
deux cuillères à soupe de lait
[Musique]
et les 60 g de beurre
on laisse refroidir
et pendant ce temps du ces par les
jaunes et les blancs des 6e
[Musique]
tu as besoin des six blancs d'oeuf mais
de quatre jaunes seulement
[Musique]
en mélangeant les 100 g de sucre aux
quatre jaunes
tu dois obtenir une préparation blanche
et mousseuse
[Musique]
alalalala
aulas
on a rajouté au chocolat les jaunes
d'oeufs et le sucre
là
aulas
voilà
nous
alors
ah la la
ah là là là
les six blancs d'oeuf doivent être
battus en neige très ferme pour réussir
l'opération ajoute une pincée de sel
[Musique]
alors
très très délicatement incorpore aussi
blanc d'oeuf montés en neige
la préparation au chocolat
le
voilà
la la la
la la la la la
non
ah là là là
[Musique]
la mousse au chocolat doit être placé au
réfrigérateur pendant 2 heures avant
d'être consommée
e
non
l'heure du goûter est arrivé
e
bon appétit
[Musique]